in this video I'll be introducing the
concept of subsets and supersets the
dots on the board here represent
elements of a set the lines represent
the sets themselves these lines have
been labeled B a and u we can say that B
is a subset of a because B contains
because all elements of B are elements
of a we can also say that B is a proper
subset of a because all elements of B
are elements of a and there are elements
of a that are not within the set B we
can also say that the set a is a
superset of the set B because a contains
all of the elements of B and being even
more specific we can say that a is a
proper superset of B because a contains
all elements of B and there are elements
of a that are not elements of B what we
cannot say is that U is a proper subset
of a although the circle here is bigger
than a like it just takes up more space
it doesn't contain any more elements so
all the elements so u contains all
elements of a however u does not contain
any extra elements so U is a subset of a
and a is actually a subset of U U is a
superset of a and a is also a superset
of U so these sets a and u in this case
are actually equal